Okay so I know most of you guys are
probably nursing a hangover from last
night but I really need you to pay
attention for the next 10 minutes it's
pretty important okay there is a
question that every single person
graduating tomorrow knows the answer to
some of us more certain of this question
than others and many of us actually come
to Harvard to figure this out but even
if we don't know the answer it's a
question that we ask ourselves often and
it's something we spend four years
trying to figure out what am I gonna do
with my talents some of us are gonna
change lives and classrooms around the
world reimagining how education is
practiced and theorized some will use
their talents to take your patience and
cure disease many are going to become
lawyers and legislators still others
writers actors comics and heads of state
and I'd be lying if I didn't think about
this question myself but I felt more
lost about this question this is because
I like so many other students at this
university was lost about my place at
Harvard whether I belonged and what I
could possibly hope to contribute to
such a vast and hallowed institution I
am one of the nation's eleven point
three million undocumented immigrants my
father finds work as a line cook in
restaurants across New York City and my
mother finds work in beauty salons so if
you've ever eaten at a Korean restaurant
or receive the mani-pedi in New York
City congratulations
like it or not you may have partially
subsidized the education of what Fox
News would call an illegal alien my
parents are actually here today
mo- thank you, papa - don't cry I knew
early on that my talents were merely a
testament to their sacrifice a product
of their original dream to secure a
better life for me and so I knew most of
all that my talents were not my own
they were molded by my parents labor
shaped by their bowed legs and their
blistered hands my talents are
indistinguishable from their labor they
are one in the same
thus this perspective I brought with me
to Harvard gave new meaning to the
question of what am I going to do with
my talents
I felt bound to my community I felt
beholding to my undocumented people
particularly those in my home in Queens
my immigration status is always affected
the way that I see the world affected
the way that I envision my place in
society and by extension what I wanted
to do with my so-called talents and so I
wondered what am I gonna do with my
talents in the face of this impossible
question I searched for my answer at the
center of all human knowledge Widener
Library to be specific under Widener
there's a small yet indispensable part
of Harvard called the Pussey archives
which is home to many of the private
documents of distinguished Harvard
faculty I found the answer to this
question buried in the personal library
of John Rawls a famous political
philosopher at Harvard who according to
President Clinton helped the whole
generation of Americans revive their
faith and democracy itself and this is
definitely true for me at a time when
the President of the United States
believes that I don't belong here John
Rawls helped me envision in America
shaped by principles of justice fair
inclusion and human equality so Rawls
tells us that there's a sense in which
this question we all ask ourselves what
am I going to
do with my talents has hidden within it
a false assumption this assumption is
the commonly held belief that our
talents are gifts of intelligence health
wealth charm wit and abilities is
something we can claim as our own Rawls
challenges us to question whether our
talents are something we can truly claim
ownership over like D Hall plates or
that last piece of chicken breasts blow
the grill closes indeed Rawls says that
one's talents are merely the product of
luck an arbitrary force dispensed to
humans based on no moral standard
thus he argued we must think about our
talents as a collective asset a common
asset that must be leveraged as part of
a well-regulated political union ok so
now to be sure some of you were thinking
but these are my talents I was the one
who worked to cultivate them I was the
one who spent all those hours at Lamont
and I was the one who shed sweat tears
and peppermint Rubinoff to perfect my
abilities I deserve what flows from my
talents why should I think about it as a
common asset like a public restroom or
John Harvard's foot now hear me out hear
me out what I'm saying
is that thinking about our talents as a
collective asset helps us escape the
language that often surrounds the
conversations that we have with each
other at Harvard we often swim in a
culture that says talented people get
what they deserve right that those with
higher GPAs are smarter that those who
get punched by final clubs are cooler
than those who do not that those who
work at Goldman are more brilliant than
those who do not alright maybe that's my
last what isn't true but we swim in this
culture that says what you get is tied
to your talents in reality our talents
are products of social collaboration our
intelligence charm and abilities only
blossom when others believe and invest
in us I think this is clearest at
Harvard
the only thing I would venture to say is
true for every single person in our
class is that not one of us could have
gotten to this point on our own dining
hall workers nourish our bodies
librarians and archivists preserve the
knowledge and heritage we rely on to
write our papers and landscapers and
custodial staff make our campus a
beautiful place for us to completely
ignore as we swipe away on tinder our TFs and professors sit down with us time
and time again to explain for the
hundredth time things like how a
protease inhibitor works or why the hell
Nietzsche was so angry indeed our
talents are developed through
interaction with others in a web what
Rawls called a close knitted an
interconnected political community
composed both of people you know but
more by people you do not and once we
accept this there's no reason why the
duties we have to those we know
shouldn't also extend to those we do not
indeed there's no reason why the close
bonds of fellowship we often feel to our
family and friends shouldn't also extend
to those we don't know in our political
union and that's why Rawls is vision of
society as a political community is more
than a catchphrase when we share a
society your life affects mine whether
we know each other or not and we have to
evaluate this joint project by the hole
because if you think about it our
particular positions within the web of
society come to us most of all through
fortune not desert therefore how we
treat everyone in our union not just
those who are talented is really a
reflection of our personal values who we
want to care about who we want to
include and who we want to protect at
Harvard we can often be blind to the
fact that we have duties to one another
that demand
more from us than simple
non-interference, non-interference that
says i'll do with my talents what I will
and you do with your talents what you
will non-interference that says we
should draw the line of membership in
our society only around those who
possess talents on the contrary we have
a positive responsibility to others a
duty to liberate those who are unable to
wonder what am I going to do with my
talents and I know this isn't easy it's
not easy because it demands that we
reject this notion that we can truly own
our talents it demands that we step up
and own our good fortune enough to give
its fruits away but if it's any
consolation there's a reason that the
inscription facing you as you leave the
yard says depart to serve better thy
country and mankind not depart to serve
better thyself and I can thus I believe
truly taking this adage seriously and
taking it to heart requires us to ask
ourselves a slightly different form of
the question we all know the answer to
what am I going to do for others with my
talents thank you
you